you think is going to be possible to
basically subtract out the effect of the
foreground dust and see if there is a
residual that is left over from the big
Bank the question that we have is can we
do it using modeling and the bicep team
have gotten quite good at this with Warn
and data from their own data set rather
than relying on the plank data which are
not as sensitive now for the first time
yes we can remove it we've already
removed a lot of foregrounds for many of
our experiments including dust but the
question is what level of ultimate
sensitivity remains will that noise
level swamp the underlying inflationary
signal well then you have to tell me
which one of the 10,000 different models
of inflation you choose the answer is we
don't know because nobody knows what
level inflation took place at or if
inflation took place at all